well in Clark County crossing guards are
only stationed at elementary schools but
just that Staffing is becoming even more
difficult to achieve as Ryan Matthey
reports there are safety concerns if
this shortage persists
with big signs come big responsibility
Clark County crossing guards making sure
your student gets to and from school
safely but workers are losing interest
and schools are losing crossing guards
it's an hour in the morning an hour in
the afternoon Simone Essen took on that
role in 2017. we'll ask them to say or
like I did with you don't know go back
it's through the company Clark County
contracts with to hire them she's now a
manager but still does entry-level
duties they'll give notice the same day
we've had difficulty hiring or just
interest in the positions she says they
staff over 800 schools county-wide a
thousand crossing guards needed to
comfortably do that but how many
personnel stay on changes daily so would
you call this a shortage yes
a shortage in the hundreds she says
brought on by seniors who are retiring
young people choosing other jobs and
recent changes to school start and end
times which doesn't give enough travel
time between campuses it's children's
jobs to be unpredictable the UNLV Road
Equity Alliance project says it's been
working to expand crossing guard access
to Middle Schools but now director Aaron
Breen concerned of getting this shortage
fixed first the potential for kids
making bad decisions gets greater
because there's not an adult there if we
don't cover there could be an accident
you know if we're late getting to a
crosswalk you know within that 10 15
minutes or even one minute someone could
be hurt
now we can also tell you that the
requirements are actually pretty
manageable crossing guards must be over
18 and pass an agility and a balanced
test